the girlfriend in the other dimension
the mushroom once I said to it to her I
almost said once I said to her I said
what should I call you and she said call
me Dorothy
[Laughter]
so I invoke it and it comes it comes and
then and then we're off and sometimes
it's easy and loving and sometimes it's
different I remember one very epic trip
I had where I had tossed out a big
compost pile from growing mushrooms
years ago in another country it actually
was a past life I'm now recalling but
anyway I tossed out this stuff and this
thing grew this humongous mushroom and I
had taken mushrooms the previous
Saturday I had taken a full dose which
is five dried grams so I thought I want
to take mushrooms again this Saturday
but I I think I may have picked up a
tolerance so I'll just take nine grams
instead and this is where the learning
takes place the mistakes treasure your
mistakes so the thing it's like I'm
sitting there and suddenly I realize oh
my god it's coming at me it's a hundred
miles wide it's ten miles high and it is
rolling toward me it looks and and I
barely had time to lay down that's how
fast it and a boy said you know yet
prepare the storm is about to hit the
beach and and I laid down and it was
just it was like a tornado hitting and
at one point I opened my eyes and the
there was this woman in a full bondage
gatah
with the you know piercings and rubber
panty
and the whole thing and she and I was
lying there between her legs she was
standing upright and and she put her
face right down to mine and she said is
it strong enough for you [ __ ] to
which I replied yes and she said and
then she said they say it helps to close
your eyes cowboy and I later in thinking
about that trip I realized the reason
the goddess
the reason the mushroom addressed me as
cowboy is because that's most people
mushrooms have met have been cowboys and
cowgirls cuz they're the people who
follow the cows and most people have
encountered this thing in the pasture
you know Maria Sabina the mushroom
shamaness of Oaxaca claimed not to have
been initiated she claimed that as a
child left to watch the sheep and the
cows she had been hungry and had gotten
into eating mushrooms once I was in
India and I was cornered this guy I was
loaded actually on mescaline and this
guy swam aboard my my houseboat and
normally I just would run these guys off
because they were thieves and beggars
but I was so loaded that I couldn't do
anything but sit there and this guy came
up to me and sat down across from me and
looked at me and after a few minutes he
said face his index of mind
and I said Ron gee I can't beat
arrogated now but it was this thing he
could see faces index of mine my mind
was swirling visibly there
[Music]
you